il s'est engagé dans la guérilla
révolutionnaire avant d'être accusé d'un
double meurtre voici l'histoire de
Pierre Goldman il y a une fascination il
y a une séduction qui s'exerce un jeune
homme brun vient de tuer deux femmes
dans une pharmacie il est un personnage
qui qui symbolisait beaucoup des
fantômes de ce siècle finalement
personne n'est sûr que il est totalement
innocent
[Musique]
nous sommes le 19 décembre 1969 à Paris
aux alentours de 20h30 un homme entre
dans une pharmacie située au 6 boulevard
Richard Lenoir et tire sur plusieurs
personnes un policier alerté qui tente
d'intercepter le gangster et blessé à
son tour d'une balle dans le ventre
très méditerranéen qui parle d'un homme
Brunk certains disent une casquette
qu'il avait pas de casquette il va par
dessus un imperméable enfin voilà c'est
un homme sans visage et tout l'objet de
du procès c'est de savoir si cet homme
est Pierre Goldman ou pas à la suite
d'une dénonciation Pierre Goldman est
arrêtée il a 25 ans fils de résistant
juif polonais très marqué par ses
origines et révoltées par
l'antisémitisme il est tombé dans la
délinquance après un passage dans les
groupes révolutionnaires d'Amérique du
Sud il n'est pendant la guerre déjà ce
qui est pas du tout anodin à la fin de
la guerre ses parents vont se séparer sa
mère retourne vivre en Pologne et il est
reconnu par son père et adopté par sa
belle-mère officiellement il y a un
fantasme énorme sur la mer qui est une
révolutionnaire une héroïne et tout ça
et et surtout pour Goldman il a toute sa
vie cherchait à être à la hauteur de ses
parents en fait adolescent turbulent
Pierre Goldman fait plusieurs séjours en
établissement psychiatrique à 15 ans il
est renvoyé des Jeunesses communistes et
s'engagent au sein des services d'ordre
d'organisation étudiante d'extrême
gauche qui retourne voir sa mère elle
lui fait sa culture
historique mais aussi politique
Auschwitz la résistance tout ça à la fin
des années 60 il rejoint Cuba et
s'engage dans la lutte armée
révolutionnaire au Venezuela
il vit sur un fantasme il veut être à la
hauteur de la vie de ses parents mais en
fait il arrive toujours trop tard il
arrive à La Havane le soir de la mort du
Che il dit quand j'arrive la révolution
est finie donc il tourne en rond et
finalement ils finissent par braquer une
banque et il a basculé de l'idée à la
révolutionnaire au banditisme mais c'est
vrai que la vie de Goldman
intellectuellement c'est brillant mais
dans les faits c'est une suite d'échec
de retour en France Pierre Goldman
commet plusieurs braquages avant d'être
arrêté pour le double meurtre du
boulevard Richard Lenoir à première vue
tout la câble dans l'affaire du
boulevard Richard Lenoir les témoins
l'ont reconnu et s'il nie les faits
Pierre Goldman admet cette retrouvée
dans le quartier pour commettre une
autre agression à laquelle au dernier
moment il aurait renoncé de plus il a
déjà attaqué une pharmacie le lundi que
dit aux policiers qu'il a commis quatre
braquages dont ce braquage qui a coûté
la mort de pharmacienne et les trois au
braquages Goldman les avoue très
facilement les policiers ont toutes les
raisons de croire qu'il a fait les
quatre en 1974 Pierre Goldman est jugé
aux assises à Paris malgré l'absence de
preuve ainsi que de nombreuses
incohérences parmi les témoignages il
est condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité un verdict qui a provoqué des
mouvements divers c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire dans la salle de danse
il est plus ou moins établi qu'il y ait
eu des bavures
spécialement dans les procédures de
reconnaissance
d'identification
de l'auteur présumé tout cet amalgame de
d'un cohérence
ne peut pas ne pas engendrer un
sentiment de doux
incarcéré à la prison de Fresnes Pierre
Goldman se consacre à l'écriture et
publie son autobiographie dans laquelle
il clame son innocence
ce qui a frappé les gens à l'époque
c'est que c'était un livre extrêmement
bien écrit en fait il a été aussi
accueilli comme une oeuvre littéraire un
comité de soutien se forme autour de
Pierre Goldman avec à l'appui de
nombreuses figures artistiques et
intellectuelles comme Jean-Paul Sartre
Simone de Beauvoir Simone Signoret
Pierre Mendès France ou encore Françoise
Sagan l'affaire Goldman inspire même une
chanson à Maxime Le Forestier je dis que
de bien
[Musique]
le temps prison normalement du petit
milieu intellectuel de gauche parisien à
l'époque autour de lui le moment où
Goldman devient un peu une popstar c'est
le deuxième procès Pierre Goldman
comparaîtra de nouveau le 26 avril
prochain mais cette fois devant les
assises de la somme des assises qui
s'isant après les faits devront dire si
Pierre Goldman et bien l'auteur du
hold-up du boulevard Richard Lenoir un
procès qui reflète peut-être également
le malaise et les doutes de notre
société il a beaucoup de supporters dans
la salle et ça lui plaît d'emmener la
salle avec lui se rendant pas compte que
en fait il joue une partition
extrêmement dangereuse il est
extrêmement provocateur il résiste
jamais au plaisir du bon mot voilà il
révérencieux il est progressif Pierre
Goldman sous-entendez-vous que la police
de ce pays est raciste non seulement je
le sous-entends mais je l'affirme et
bien c'est
[Applaudissements]
une autre je pense que ce que mon client
a voulu dire c'est que certains
policiers peuvent parfois avoir un
comportement raciste certainement pas
que le corps policier dans son ensemble
est raciste non non je veux dire que la
police est raciste absolument toute la
police
finalement faute de preuve il y a ce que
la parole donc on s'est parole contre
parole lui dit les témoins sont des
racistes on a frisé l'hurricule ce
témoin a répété que c'était pas un
français il avait l'air arabe est-ce que
cet homme est bien Goldman oui je le
reconnais monsieur le Président est-ce
que Goldman a l'air arabe ben non
monsieur le Président il a eu
l'intelligence à l'instant et
probablement aussi la sincérité de
politiser son procès le sort de Pierre
Goldman se joue en ce moment dans la
salle des jurés du Palais de Justice
d'Amiens doit-on condamner au bénéfice
du doute ou à quitter sur la présomption
de l'innocence voilà où la justice est
concernée toute entière après quatre
jours de procès mouvementée le nouveau
verdict tombe cette fois Pierre Goldman
est déclaré innocent du double meurtre
du boulevard Richard Lenoir on est
heureux je crois que les gens qui
étaient dans la salle ont montré que
qui ont retrouvé une justice je sais que
pour mon père ça représente énormément
et je crois que pour tout le monde il
est innocenté au bénéfice du doute
il est pas innocenté parce qu'on est sûr
qu'il est innocent à sa sortie de prison
Pierre Goldman collabore quelques temps
au journal Libération et se consacre à
la musique il publie également un roman
dans lequel le personnage principal qui
lui ressemble étrangement commet une
série de meurtres
beaucoup de se défenseurs en 1979 il vit
dans le 13e arrondissement de Paris avec
sa femme épousée en prison ensemble ils
attendent un enfant aujourd'hui à 12h30
en plein Paris dans le 13e
arrondissement Pierre Goldman a été
abattu à coup de pistolet par trois
inconnus c'est sur cette petite place
calme devant le café où il était connu
que Pierre Goldman a été assassiné un
commando de tueurs était au rendez-vous
touchant ou de loin
[Musique]
de compte de la police d'un syndicat de
la police ou le policier d'extrême
droite enfin voilà c'est toutes les
pistes possibles les trois hommes qui
l'ont tué aujourd'hui près de son
domicile à Paris en revendiquait
l'attentat ils affirment appartenir à
une organisation qui a pour titre
honneur de la police l'Agence France
Presse recevait un message téléphoné
Pierre Goldman a payé ses crimes la
justice du pouvoir ayant montré une
nouvelle fois ses faiblesses et son
laxisme nous avons fait ce que notre
devoir nous commandait je dois dire que
je ne crois en tout cas pas du tout à
une vengeance policière je suis sûr
qu'un groupe fascisant dont je ne peux
savoir même si les Français ou non mais
en tout cas un groupe fascisant ça j'en
suis sûr se cache derrière cette
appellation trop commode honneur de la
police lors de ses obsèques plus de
10000 personnes défilent dans les rues
de Paris et de nombreuses personnalités
sont présentes pour lui rendre hommage
Simone de Beauvoir Jean-Paul Sartre et
André glutzman parmi de nombreux autres
intellectuels se sont recueillis sur sa
tombe de nombreux antillais aussi
puisque Pierre Goldman avait épousé une
antillaise dont il a eu hier un fils
posthume les Noirs
afro cubains ou antillais je veux dire
était pour lui je veux dire une un
peuple qu'il appréhendait exactement de
la même manière qu'il appréhendait sa
judéité c'est-à-dire comme un peuple qui
revenait ou qui survivait à une très
longue extermination qui avait été celle
de la traite des lois à ce jour le
meurtre de Pierre Goldman n'a toujours
pas été élucidé
[Musique]